[Music]
[Applause]
I
know
me why would you bet on Goliath when we
got bet David value taming giving values
contagious this world are entrepreneurs
we get no value to haters run homie what
I become
[Music]
I'm episode 303 a lot going on right now
with one being open AI 700 out of
770 employees at a company worth 86
billion doll have threatened to leave
and possibly go to Microsoft to follow a
man called uh Sam Alman who was fired by
the board and Microsoft only found out a
minute prior to that we're going to talk
about today if you can just go to Tom
and see how much how much how many pie
of paper he
got ready for that in my area two we
have Argentina had a uh uh Wild Man the
Elvis of Argentina uh uh wins the
election we got a couple Clips to show
one that no one's ever seen before we
may you know show you a glimpse of that
uh clip as well he he lost it he lost it
that one clip no one's ever seen we show
that here to you and we got a few other
things going on we have uh Roger Stone
in the house the reason why Roger
Stone's in the house is one because uh
this man's got very interesting takes
he's lived a very he's a qualified
you're you're a qualified Unusual
Suspect I was qualified but also
tomorrow happens to be the 60e
anniversary of the assassination of
johnf Kennedy and one of the best books
written on that uh New York Times
bestseller the man who killed Kennedy a
case against LBJ if you've never read
this book we're going to put the link
below as well for you to go order this
book and uh we're going to talk about
that as well so Rogers great great to
have you on great to be here yes so we
got a lot to go through story-wise I say
we get right into it if that's okay with
you let's do it so let's start off with
uh I want to say let's start off with uh
open AI okay let's start off with open
AI on what happened over the weekend so
Microsoft says Altman Brockman will lead
new in-house AI team which makes no
sense because when you think about Chad
gbt you think about a man named Sam
Alman okay and let me let me read a
little bit more on what Microsoft is
telling us here so Sam Alman has been
appointed who's the co-founder of open
AI to lead its new in-house AI team with
Microsoft following alman's outting from
his startup Microsoft SEO satian Adela
Express in enthusiasm for this move
stating I'm super excited to have you
join as CEO of this new group Sam
setting a new pace for Innovation this
decision comes after a series of
dramatic events involving Microsoft and
open AI including Alman and Greg
Brockman leaving the latter company
Microsoft has been investing heavily in
open AI with a roughly 49% stake and a
significant focus on integrating open AI
technology into its lineup uh apparently
700 out of their 7 70 employees at open
AI have sit there're leaving the
partners said there're leaving a bunch
of different things are going on no one
has more insight on this than our friend
here Tom Tom what is your take on what's
going on here with open AI well a bunch
of things have happened overnight I
think everybody saw and everybody even
if you are a sportson news fan and we're
only watching football over the weekend
you saw that the board um uh a guy named
Ilia skver um goes to the board and says
hey you know we got a lot of concerns
here with Sam um and they fire him on
Friday all hell breaks loose Microsoft
is like hey what was that what's going
on down there they didn't even know
about it and then on Saturday you know
Altman's like I don't know if I want to
go back maybe I do maybe I don't and
Sunday Alman goes to the um to the
office there and it's funny he he tweets
or he puts a post on X of a guest badge
like here he is can you show this
picture yeah he says uh
first and last time I would to be
wearing a guest badge at this company
that I've been driving in the future of
AI well yesterday some really crazy
things happen so let's let's add to it
yesterday Microsoft says you know with
700 Microsoft's got a$ 13 billion
investment in here and you've got um
Thrive Capital Coosa Ventures and tiger
tiger Go Global by the way coasta
Ventures led by the great you know venod
kosla himself who is saying Hey I want I
want Sam back there Thrive says me too
tiger says me too because they all have
investment in open Ai and Microsoft is
like well you know we'll work with
Altman no matter what is what uh nadela
said and then nadela said you know
irrespective where Sam is Microsoft or
back at open AI something he said
yesterday he said he's working with
Microsoft so nadela looks at it that way
I've got $13 billion in open AI if he's
working for us with Brockman that's
great yesterday yesterday something
broke that was very interesting Elia
sever officiated Greg brockman's wedding
to him and
an there's a close Dynamic there Elia
did not think Brockman was going to walk
with Sam wow did not think so and it it
is and so when he does that and all the
employees have now signed this the other
investor are worried now wait a minute
because nadela goes yesterday on news
coverage and says at this point I think
it's very clear something has to change
around governance for the future and for
all of them that wish to leave you have
opportunities to work on our AI
initiative at Microsoft so Microsoft is
basically saying hey don't worry about
benefits if you leave you're here which
led the other investors to completely
freak out and yesterday if you got the
if you got the uh
tweet Elia says I am making a U-turn so
this is what he did elas says I deeply
regret my participation in the board's
action I never wanted to harm open AI I
love everything we built and I'll do
everything I can
to reunite the company and so same guy
that broke it apart is willing to
reunite now you saw that Sam
responded Pat would you accept this from
any body I don't think you would as a
leader you know what's going on I regret
my participation in the board's action
the board's action you went to the board
it wasn't the board's action you went to
the I regret my participation in the
board's action it's like you voted with
the board you didn't you went there and
said this is what we have to do Sam's
got to go this is what it is the other
thing that happened overnight which I
think you'll find interesting check this
out after they let Sam go they called
Dario amodi who is Dario amodi Dario
amodi is the co-founder and CEO of the
number one rival to open AI anthropic
and they said do you want to be CEO
we're letting Sam go that was the
board's plan and they said uh he said no
I don't want to do that and they said
well would you mer would you merge with
us so they're trying to merge the two so
look at what the board was doing and
before the board even got them then they
get a no from there and then the board
has to run around and before EMT Shear
accepted the role they called nat
Freedman who had been at Microsoft after
Microsoft bought GitHub then they called
Alex Wang co-founder of scale AI the
board was in complete freakout mode
after they let Sam go and all this was
going down and they're calling anthropic
and they're trying to merge and they're
calling these people and this and then
700 people signed a document nadela says
hey you 700 want for us that's fine I
think all of this is going to get back
together and we're going to and that
open AI Sam's going to be running it be
gone there'll be a new board and
Microsoft will be on that board so so so
here so Tom open AI 86 billion company
there was a time that they said they
started it as a nonprofit right that
they finally converted as a profit that
that's correct in 2019 they converted to
a profit after starting as a nonprofit
with people like Peter theal Elon Musk
investing so now here's a question Sam
Alman how much Equity does he have in
open AI I just Googled it right now it
says zero that's correct how why because
he was part of the he was part so he he
had more than enough to his name and he
really wanted to lead open AI so he was
leading it as the nonprofit yeah but I
mean he doesn't have a piece of equity
in open AI what why who who the hell in
the right mind would think it's a good
idea to have the founder and the COO the
company not have any equity in a $86
billion company with zero incentives
that doesn't lock him into want to who
who thought that was a good idea that is
a great question and the board converted
in 2019 because they were having trouble
recruiting Talent so they created this
organization where the board oversaw the
nonprofit which controlled and oversaw
the for-profit and had an entity created
so they could give people equity and and
part of the side and by the way Thrive
Capital wanted a bigger piece and
they're a current investor and they
wanted even more they offered to buy
some of the people's Equity so they
could have a bigger piece at at the $86
billion valuation yeah I totally get all
that stuff you're saying but but uh
here's a question for the board what
makes you think it's a good move for the
guy that should have more incentive than
anybody else for the co to own 0% equity
in the company that you can't lock in
the board are you it's not like this guy
doesn't have money he's got a few
hundred million I think he's a half a
billion a guy 700 million guy he's made
some money but you're talking about
something that goes from Z to 86 billion
with the money that he and Elon Musk put
up right because it was originally
supposed to be
a a charity a nonprofit they were all it
was all donations it said they were
forms that said that the early money put
in by Elon Musk was a donation to the
nonprofit this is this also a way where
Microsoft sister there and says we don't
care if we lose 18 13 billion we're
getting the guy and now we can own a
bigger percentage of the whole thing
that's going to be all Microsoft not not
just an investment is that kind of how
they're looking at it that's exactly how
they're looking at it and I'm going to
teach everybody a new word in Silicon
Valley there's a word called aqua hire
like acquire and hire Aqua hire so let's
say you love a group of Engineers but
they're working on something and it's
just not working out and you tell them
hey Pat um you Tom and these guys tell
you what we're going to give you five
million bucks wind down the company pay
some of your investors and law firms but
you come work for us and we're going to
give you new equity and we're going to
do this you join us that's called an
aqua hire where they basically give you
enough to close one company that hasn't
got transaction traction and come to the
other side and everybody was saying
nadela just by the way Microsoft's stock
popped up and it closed at an all-time
high $2.75 trillion at when all of this
all of this was going down on Monday and
everybody everybody in Silicon Valley is
saying you know know who the the the
biggest the biggest gorilla in the uh in
the jungle is and that's SATA Nadella he
basically just pulled off an aqua hire
where he gets the Brain Trust of open AI
up to 700 people coming to work for him
for the price of 13 billion dollar and
if he wanted to buy and just acquire
open AI it would have cost
86 that's a uh very interesting by the
way some may say $13 billion is a lot of
money it is a lot of money but it's like
having three 2,7 $50 and you're
investing into something 13 bucks it's
kind of what it means like it is money
but it's not really that much money to
Microsoft Adam I think um and Tom great
breakdown thank you that's by the way
you know 12 Trees died for that story so
I don't want Tom doing my opposition
research going forward he will you do
not want to get on the wrong side ofer
it would be a privilege to work with you
you're you are a I think um one thing
that we shouldn't lose sight of am
amongst all this this artificial
intelligence and artificial general
intelligence and basically robot
learning uh everything still comes down
to humanity and being a human one of the
words Tom you said one of the words that
you just learned before all this was
what was it called aqua what was it
called aquire aqu acquisition up until
about a year ago a a term that I've
never heard of I mean I get it was the
whole being a humanist do you remember
that Elon Musk basically said listen
when it comes to AI you have to
understand that I'm a humanist which
that's never been a thing where you need
to advocate for being a human but that's
essentially what this comes down to uh
in the midst of all this of AI and
artificial intelligence especially when
building a company it still comes down
to interpersonal relationships and
clearly there were some major issues
going on within the board within Sam
within everything and it's good to know
that humans are still running companies
uh despite everything that's going on
here and and in fact that was actually
the uh Crux of the issue that was going
on here so if you look at what this guy
Ilia has said uh over the last year it's
all about the safety concerns of AI and
how it affects Humanity he argued that
basically human values uh and humanism
needs to be at the Forefront of
everything that's going on here he
basically said that uh the company needs
to uh set up a super alignment team with
20% of the company's computing power to
ensure the safety of humans so it's good
to know that people are looking out for
Humanity here he basically said that um
he told employees that the biggest
concerned AGI will treat humans the way
that humans treat animals basically like
red alert like humans could become
second class citizens with the Advent of
um AGI and then just to kind of put a
ribbon on this I don't know if you saw
this that Biden recently by the way
shout out to our friend Joe Biden it's
it's his 81st birthday so I know that
people I know we're going out to the
club tonight to celebrate I don't even
think he knows but he signed an execu A
Day under 90 that's
true that's true he set up a uh he
signed an executive order basically um
with AI oversight he invoked the defense
protection act defense production act
which basically highlights privacy and
National Security uh in regard to things
like deep fakes and all that so uh
amidst all this that's going on and
Tom's amazing breakdown it's good to
know that humanity is still at the
Forefront what do you think about the
story look I ai ai to me is a great
piece in the Wall Street Journal about
10 days ago I think it's extraordinarily
dangerous because as the headline says
nothing will be real so at least within
the world of politics uh you can produce
a video now seamlessly that makes it
appear that your opponent or those you
oppose say and do things that they never
said and done I've been a victim of this
so therefore I think it's extraordinary
dangerous and voters don't necessarily
have discernment so oh I know Biden said
that because I saw a video of him saying
except for he never said it or or Barack
Obama you said you were a victim of this
oh God there's a there's a ton of deep
fakes on online they're not very well
done by the way but but a lot of stuff
out there sure well I have a few enemies
you know so it is so you choose your
enemies wisely so so you know going back
to this I think every time there is an
era of like an Oklahoma Land Rush people
lose their minds right now this is not a
trillion doll idea this is probably A1
10 trillion doll idea what open AI is
okay so you know how 86 billion dollar
is what it's worth today okay if this is
A10 trillion idea over the next 10 years
what is 86 billion what is 10 trillion
divided by $86 billion you know what it
is it's roughly
110x what it is
today maybe even 120x 115x what it is
today that means you invest a billion
dollars over the next 10 years that
billion could be what $15 billion okay
that is the power of what this company
is capable of doing these board members
you know these 770 employees have said
we are not coming back unless if the
board resigns correct oh wow there
there's only 770 employees 700 employees
have said we are leaving if s Alman was
fired and the board has so imagine how a
company Works you're sitting in the
board like who Do You Think You Are We
Own the board and we own the shares and
we own this and you're fired Sam Sam you
own nothing you get an email from 700
employees saying hey board I know you
got all this power guess what you want
to fire Sam if you don't fire yourself
you may as well fire us because we're up
we're going to go elsewhere guess where
that 700's going to go to straight to
one company guess what that company's
called it's called Microsoft you know
what happens to Microsoft all of a
sudden Microsoft becomes the first 10 10
trillion auto company in America in the
world Tom uh there's something else here
we're talking about the board the board
the board for those of you that have a
business or those you may be serving on
a nonprofit board is everything there
were nine seats on this board that were
occupied at the beginning of the year
nine one of them by Reed Hoffman who is
the founder of LinkedIn who ended up
sort of at Microsoft cuz Microsoft owns
LinkedIn now so what's really
interesting about is Reed Hoffman said
hey I may have a conflict and need to
step off the board two other people this
year stepped off the board this is a
normal thing most people will sit on
boards either forever or less than three
years it's usually just a a time period
so guess what that took the board down
from 9 to what 6 Sam Alman said he was
kicking himself and he he was quoted on
this yesterday I was kicking myself
because I didn't replace those board
members so it went from 9 to 6 wow so
when they walked in there to do it Elia
got one board member Helen who is a
Georgetown fellow or painer or something
like that and he gets her to go along
and says the first thing we need to do
so let's do the count there's six people
on the board Elia walks in first thing
we need to do is let's vote to remove
Greg Brockman from the board because
he'll probably vote with Sam yep all
those in favor yes four it's okay we' we
have four votes that would be four to if
they were here to vote boom they move
them now there's five people on the
board you see where this is going and
now let's vote to remove Sam well Sam
can't vote and he doesn't need to vote
and he doesn't even have to be present
because they have Quorum present so then
these four people did it so you see what
happened boards are supposed to be large
and diverse to have opinions to have
diversity of thought and to debate and
process thing and have sensible people
coming from different angles the smaller
the board gets the Dumber the board gets
or shall we say the more not Dumber but
maybe the more um blind spots blind
spots spontaneous and so you also don't
want it to be too big you don't want it
to be 15 17 correct 9 11 nine and seven
are the most popular numbers because
they're odd numbers uh as as you might
imagine but take a look at that Pat
you've had companies where you've had
boards and there's part of what happened
is they boiled it down to four people
made the decision on this and that's
what uh look what Mark benhoff just said
right here I just send this to Rob Mark
benof Salesforce uh will match any open
AI researcher who has tendered their
resignation will will full cash and
Equity ot to immediately join join our
Salesforce uh Einstein trusted AI
research team under Sylvio Savar send me
your CV directly to coo salesforce.com
Einstein is the most successful
Enterprise AI platform completing 1
trillion predictive and generative uh uh
transactions this week join our trusted
AI Enterprise uh Revolution
it is a dog eat dog dog eat dog type of
an environment right now everybody wants
to recruit the talent leaving open AI
everybody and Microsoft now either
controls it and they're going to have a
board seat in the restructure you better
believe that or they own it they either
absorb it or they own it but I don't
think the other these are Big other
investors that I think are going to want
to see open AI like put back together
with a strong board but it's basically
going to be Microsoft's toy dude Elon
just TW retweeted he says drop the open
AI just Microsoft it's cleaner like Mark
Zuckerberg what did I just say it's
Microsoft
toys the biz do kind of touched on it
but I just want to get your opinion on
this when a board fires the CEO and
founder yeah right I want to know what
that looks like internally and then
externally how that affects the company
so like we all saw that happen with
Steve Jobs in in what like the late 80s
we saw recently with uh our buddy James
O'Keefe now the latest with Sam Alman
what does that look like when this
happens when the board fires the C well
let me okay you bring up James o'keef
when's the last time he followed project
Veritas when James was there yeah that's
what brought attention they went belly
up actually I know but but we're tied to
a personality right so until the brand
becomes bigger then that person goes
away it's timing for example Steve Jobs
passed away at 56 years old every body
thought M uh what do you call Apple's
done with it wasn't Apple ended up going
from a hundred billion doll company to
A3 trillion company because at that
point Apple was bigger than jobs 100
billion today is not a lot but 100
billion when Steve Jobs died what year
the Jobs died Rob is it 2006 or 2008
what is the Year Steve Jobs died could
have been 11 one uh 2011 okay so he dies
in 2011 everybody's like it's over with
12 years later it's a$3 trillion company
but by that time Apple was is already
established you cannot do it with early
stage Founders and when you fir the the
CEO in many cases it's valid like this
guy did something okay like when uh Uber
fired
uh him with Dana yeah in many cases it
it's but for example like even remember
when uh uh New Year's Eve Dana White his
wife and everybody said oh he should get
fired he should get this you should take
time away he's like screw you no I'm not
taking time away I screwed up I'm going
have to deal with this with my family
you think I'm embarrassed about what you
think no I'm embarrassed with my own
family let me deal there so Bor got
pressure from media Bor got pressure
from left media Bor got pressure from a
couple investors and Bor pitched to Dana
maybe want to take a month or two months
off this is speculation and then Dana
came back and said you talking about I'm
not doing this I'm here
if they would have fired
Dana I mean it's the ultimate black guy
for the brand of uh UFC good word used
by the way by the way black eyy UFC yeah
you had to nail that head basically so
the the the whole thing becomes like you
can't get rid of a guy that's got that
kind of loyalty from the audience and
obviously guess what Sam Alman just
proved he's got it and Sam Alman has
been arguably the face of AI like name
anyone else when you associate with AI
but you said a lot of times with the
board fires the CEO it is valid yeah
many times you why is that listen if
you're you know how many times they give
the money and Co gets a couple dollars
and then he goes cruising a little bit
and coule couple dollars off the table
and you know he stops being accountable
gets to his head arrogant you know
doesn't come to work becomes casual
become that happens a lot what's the the
The Works Space thing that everyone used
to we work work exactly what happened
with that guy Adam he's still a
billionaire and and he's still going to
get money and he's still going to raise
money cuz he's crazy enough to get money
but many times it does make sense you
know the the the last shout on here is
Sam Alman um he's also known as y
combinator he led Y combinator which is
like the single most successful and
fruitful ex you know small business
accelerator that's ever been known to
mankind and it at the end of the chapter
there they were saying Sam you know
you're working on open AI you're working
on all these projects can you really
give the time to why combinator
shouldn't you step away from this
because you're doing actually too many
things so Sam did he stepped away from
why combinator as as the as the leader
and one of the things that happened
recently is he was over with the Saudis
talking to pif uh which is the Saudi
fund and he was asking them about
investing in a company that would design
and make AI chips to compete with Nvidia
because he thought that Nvidia having
too much market share was like
monopolistic and that wouldn't be good
and he didn't want to have ai's Reliance
on one company so he was out doing that
actively trying to raise money for that
as well as in in the billions of dollars
so they said the board was also
concerned about him maybe doing too many
things and they said it was a breakdown
in communication uh I think we'll know I
think more will come out there'll be
things that come out I don't want to be
like literal Tom here's all you need to
know if 700 out of 770 are saying
they're going to leave he was doing more
than enough to have the lawyer of 7 770
uh I'll wrap it up with this and we'll
go to the Argentina story when you find
a Relentless founder who's driven bought
into Vision worker has technical skills
it is very very hard to find people like
that very hard to find people like that
because they increase valuation and
that's exactly what he was doing Rob
let's go to the next story so wild story
out of nowhere you hear Argentina elects
shock therapy libertarian Javier Millie
as the president reuter story so
Argentina likes libertarian outside of
aier M as its new president with nearly
56% the vote he pledged economic shock
therapy and stated Argentina situation
is critical the changes our country
needs are drastic melee radical plans
include shutting down to Central Bank
ditching the peso and implementing
spending cuts he resonated with voters
frustrated by the economic crisis and
One support particularly among the young
M Victory disrupts Argentina's political
landscape and economic Direction he has
criticized China and Brazil emphasizing
stronger us ties however he faces the
challenge of a fragmented Congress and
addressing the country's economic woes
Rob can you play one of the clips let's
go to the clip of him uh giving the
message with a lady he's doing an
interview with yeah right there if you
can make this oneir guys just read the
caption first of all he looks like an
Argentinian Elvis Presley but but watch
what he's saying read the captions go
for he's a wild
man
for
it
okay what what's your reaction when you
see this first of all the only thing
worse in politics than being wrong is
being boring this guy is never boring
yeah so he understands uh that politics
is entertainment if you can't entertain
the people if you can't get their
attention then you can't educate them
and you can't persuade them at the same
time he's genuine I mean that's really
him I mean this guy he's a True Believer
you can tell he he fronted a rock a
Rolling Stones Rock Band for years uh
his dog is named Milton fredman uh he is
a he is a radical libertarian uh he is
well-versed you know in vanon misis and
Hayek uh he's put forward an
extraordinarily radical agenda uh he's
uh you know he understands symbolism he
shows up with a CH saww at one of his
press conferences he dresses in
superhero costumes uh and uh he's right
socialism has brought their country
triple digit inflation uh Al looming
recession uh and uh new levels of
poverty so uh I mean the guy is he's on
fire uh and it's people don't recognize
two important things one he's not from
either one of the two major dominant
parties who've dominated Argentine
politics for the last 40 years he's
actually a third party won this election
which has never happened before there or
here and
secondarily Argentina has 100% paper
ballots there are no voting machines and
they tabulate all their ballots on
Election Day that night now that is not
to say that vote stealing is unknown
which it just simply means that you have
to have a very aggressive pole watching
operation to make sure that no paper
ballots are are stolen so uh I thought
he might win the polling was uh much
closer but uh he he's really on fire uh
and uh he he totally understands the the
Dynamics of the dire situation uh and
that shock therapy is going to be
necessary Rob do you have the other clip
of him pulling all the tapes off and you
know off the wall this is this is
fantastic watch this one
here
[Music]
a little
bit there goes
green
gender
divers
riing
[Music]
oh my God this guy's a rockstar Long
Live Freedom d what happened in our
booking meeting yesterday I think so you
guys got to watch this watch this here
the booking meeting yesterday very
important clip go for
it gender
stud watch on fire he's on fire Vinnie's
inspired Vinnie that's awesome man I'm
worried Pat I think he's I Vinnie Vinnie
wore the uniform for the USA I'm worried
he's going to
defect so Tom what do you think about
when you see this candidate Argentina
what's happening to the world um I agree
with that Roger just said is that this
guy understands the symbolism and he
understands how he's communica ating and
he is he as a third party gets
56%
55.7% of the voting populace who are
being rocked by three things
unemployment inflation and zero vision
for the country you look at the and that
that angst is living under there as
Argentina where are we going are we
going to be this economic light for
Latin America there's no vision there's
no vision coming from the leadership and
there's inflation and employment so the
people are desperate and all of a sudden
this guy talks about turning it down and
giving him a place to go and being the
one guy that's got the balls to walk in
and do it and 55.7% say that's my guy
yeah once the one of the 10 wealthiest
countries in the world bu Aries was
considered the Paris of South America so
the country's known Prosperity but
they're in Dire Straits uh and the
Socialist he ran against was the guy in
charge of the economy talk about a bad
hand yeah so uh uh he's a friend of mine
M uh he's read my book Stones rules he
took it to heart obviously uh he's I'm I
think I'm going to go down for the
inauguration very excited about it uh
the people who ran his campaign are very
they're very young I mean they're very
digital Savvy he ran a very modern
effective campaign but it's really built
around him and his personality well by
the way go back to what you just showed
and and then Vinnie I'll come to go back
to what you just showed the data Rob 50
so check this out 99.4% of Voters Ted in
presidential runoff Mee had 55.7% and
economy Minister Sergio Masa 44%
according to Argentina's electoral
Authority it is the highest percentage
that a presidential candidate has
received since the South American
Count's return to democracy in 1983 well
and and and Rog just going off what you
said about you know them and I I think
you got to give a little credit where
credits do Roger because this type of
political attitude you were technically
the architect because you know what
Trump was running well actually in the
80s when you recommended that Trump
should run you saw the value Raj of the
outsider image he's the outsider uh also
someone who brings business experience
to the political process and because
your philosophy when it came to politics
was anti- lism not not big government so
in essence you this is the direct result
this guy's attitude this guy's Vision
this guy's like movement in the
political party Rogers because of how
you treated them in the 80s right I
think his appeal I think his whole thing
is very similar to Trump in 2016 I mean
he you know he's he's not coached I'll
tell you that he's not he's not handled
he's not managed he's not scripted uh
what you see is is what you get and
people respond to authenticity uh
particularly in dire times uh where this
guy has a very radical prescription uh
he's got a lot of obstacles there's no
question but in a larger context I see
this as a precursor for the United
States in the sense that brexit was a
precursor for Trump's election in 2016
uh this I think is an important Victory
uh for the forces of freedom and anti-
big governmen ISM I love the use of the
word precursor because one of the things
that was going on here I was seeing
Flags there Roger I'm sure you picked up
on this that said don't tread on me that
comes from the dawn of American
independence and that was a message from
that from us remember that we have to uh
what was it Thomas Payne said if we
don't hang together we will certainly
all hang separately and don't tread on
me those symbolism showing up in flags
that they're waving says that these
Argentine people who may be young and
the people that are voting understand
the importance of what we call the
American experiment yeah know they the
the young people love America they love
everything about America so it is uh and
they're very very attuned to our pop
culture it's interesting almost
everybody said good things about him
getting elect here's what Trump said
about it by the way Trump said
congratulations to million great race
for president of Argentina the whole
world was watching I'm proud of you you
will turn your country around and truly
make America great again uh truly make
Argentina great again but here's what
even Lula said good things but here is
what Colombia's president said the
extreme right has won in Argentina it's
the decision of its Society sad for
Latin America and we'll see that do do
the relationship between Colombia and
Argentina the bonds between their
communities are maintain paint in mutual
respect however I congratulate Millie
how's Columbia doing by the way how are
they doing not too good no exactly well
exactly that's right where I was going
this cuz I was in Columbia about a year
ago and I saw what was going on there if
I'm from board and raised in Miami and
I've seen basically half of Latin
America moved to Miami in the last
decade or so we all saw that basically
what happened when uh Cubans all came
here in the in the 8S everything that
happened with Fidel Castro and a
multitude of that but if you look at
what's going on in South America
obviously Cuba and Venezuela are as
Socialist Communist Marxist as it gets
but it doesn't end there if you look at
what's going on in Peru Bolivia
Argentina Chile um certainly in Mexico
um Nicaragua but then you have certain
outliers like what naibu Kelli is doing
in El Salvador credit to him he's he's a
Libertarian crypto Advocate um this guy
right here um javar Milly is the first
libertarian candidate ever elected ever
period in any country I don't know if
you know that but
um the you mentioned that you need
personality and you need policy right
this guy has a combination of both we
have arguments and debates here all the
time about well certain people have this
and certain people have this strength I
can think of a certain candidate running
for governor right now sorry running for
president right now that is great on
policy just personality he doesn't have
the a thing going on my friend but if
you recall and this guy is a what what
they call an anarcho capitalist so just
deep libertarian ties and if you look at
what from an economic standpoint what
did your friend Ronald Reagan say the
most terrifying words that you'll ever
hear is I'm from the government and I'm
here to help and that's essentially what
this guy's basically saying is like the
government overspending and the printing
of money and the inflation and uh the
economy that's going on in Argentina has
led to this and this Outsider has just
showed up with his chainsaw and
basically said we're going to end this
thing afua well Bou has proved that
change is possible that you can take a
country in deep trouble and you can
reverse that Trend uh and this is going
to be this is going to be an important
experiment in the same thing I I agree
and by the way I'm looking at this uh
the economy in
Argentina 140% inflation 40% living
below the poverty line is what led to
him winning so here's a question for a
lot of Americans does it need to go
there for you to realize what works and
doesn't work okay does California need
to go there before you realize what
works and what what doesn't work maybe
does New York need to go there before
before you realize what works and
doesn't work you know it's it's
repetitive when this takes place a
person like him comes in you
know finds out the frustration all the
people they vote for him Argentina gets
better if this guy is able to even live
and survive I was just going to say
Argentina gets better and he does what
he does and then oh this works and then
all of a sudden they bash the rich
people and they bash the wealth that's
been been made by people that once were
poor and then it goes back to now we're
rich how come we're not taking care of
our poor then you spend the money
cyclical Cycles the same way
generational wealth stays with certain
families
for few years most families generational
wealth only stays for one or two
generations before kids or grandkids
spend the hell out of the money
generational wealth also goes with
countries most countries who become very
wealthy it only stays for for one
generation or two before a socialist
shows up and wants to find a way to
spend that money to give it to the poor
to get elected and then they realize
that was not the right format and
another person comes in while we're
looking at this here's what happens the
other day numbers come out okay numbers
come out uh that Biden's presidency poll
NBC standing hits new lows amid Israel
Hamas war and this isn't a Fox news
story this isn't a brart story this is
an
NBC story President Biden's approval
rating has hit a new law of 40% with
strong disapproval of his foreign policy
and handling of the Israel Hamas
according to NBC polls a significant
drop which Rob if you don't mind just
playing the clip play the clip of what
they were saying the one yeah right
there the the one you just showed in a
picture right there is this the Steve
just watch this one here just watch
their reaction to it this is Meet the
Press go for it here it is Donald Trump
we have at 46% Biden 44 and this is
significant because this is the first
time in the history of our poll that
former president Trump beats President
Biden still within the margin of error
but still significant yeah in 2019 2020
when Trump was President he trailed all
of them this year he's trailed all of
them in our poll first time in more than
a dozen polls we've seen a result like
this some of the other ingredients that
go into that Biden has long had an
advantage over Trump on likeability look
at the start of this year 39% said they
had a positive view of Biden barely 30
of trump we've seen consistently a gap
like this now the Gap is gone 36
positive on both and actually Biden one
point more negative than Trump that's
been a significant Advantage for Biden
our PO says that Advantage at least for
now may be gone we talked about younger
voters on foreign policy and it's true
on a host of other topics disaffected
with Joe Biden we have 46% for Trump 42%
for Biden among the youngest voters the
youngest voters in the 2020 election
were Biden plus 26 this could be a
massive SE CH you hear what he just said
if you take a look here
two okay go back to what he said right
there go back 10 seconds Rob if you can
right there okay go a little bit back
three more seconds right yeah go for it
play this listen to this the youngest
voters the youngest voters in the 2020
election were Biden plus 26 this could
be a massive sea change pause it right
there so plus 26
during the election with younger voters
it's flipped 28 uh it's flipped
30% cuz now Trump is plus4 on young
voters and it used to be Biden plus 26
keep playing it if you take a look here
two all everybody sort of says hey I'm
not too nuts about the possibility of
this match up so we said let's measure
this one way and here's how we did it
Biden against an unnamed Republican this
is just a referendum on Biden basically
and look at this he goes from being dog
fight with Trump to be double digits
behind but then flip it around Trump
against an unnamed Democrat Trump goes
from leading against Biden to
be fascinating look at the state of the
race with little under a year to go
Steve Kaki great stuff thank you great
stuff and you know you know first of all
they pretend that the New York Times
sien a college poll 10 days ago didn't
show the exact same thing they pretend
that the Bloomberg morning consult poll
uh in the swing stage didn't show the
same thing oh this is shocking news this
is not shocking news this is the trend
what's significant is that NBC is now
saying it because that means Barack
Obama has decided that Joe must go
professional Democrats realize that Joe
is not up to another campaign they
cringe at the idea of an Obama Trump
debate uh that that blows their mind Jo
OB Trump pardon me I misspoke a a Biden
Trump debate pardon me thank you problem
uh and they and they uh uh Joe doesn't
want to go first of all Joe doesn't want
to lose the legal authority to Pardon
himself and his brother and his son and
other members of his family uh and uh
Jill certainly doesn't want to go it's
not it's not in coincidental to me that
on the day Barack Obama props Biden up
on X David Axel Rod is right-hand man is
out saying if we nominate Biden we're
going to lose so I think there's an
insine push going on in the Democratic
party as there's a growing
uh re uh realization that between the
impact of his of his domestic policies
his inability to perform as a candidate
uh the mixed messaging on the Middle
East where they're trying to please
everybody and therefore they please
nobody uh and the growing Scandal
surrounding corruption in the Biden
family adds up to Joe not being able to
make it again and therefore I think
they're going to try to push Roger who
who's going to make that decision to say
President Biden thank you for your
service please step aside how does the
inner workings the interner plumbing of
the DNC actually work who's making that
decision the most influential Democrat
in the country today is Barack Obama
there is no question about that and
these these Affiliated news
outlets uh respond very much uh to him
uh he can he can and the way their
convention is set up is very different
than the Republican convention so you
can dump an because of the super
delegates far more easily so the fact
that that the filing deadlines have
already passed in the Democratic primary
and caucus schedule for uh for New
Hampshire New Hampshire and Iowa have
been neutered they've taken away their
delegates to make South Carolina the
first contest a state with an absolute
majority of African-American voters in
their primary the Chicago the convention
is where Chicago uh the Obama's hometown
I have predicted for some time that
Michelle Obama is the most likely
Democratic nominee for the simple reason
more than Nome here's here's why quite
simply you have a an African pardon me
you have a woman of color who's the vice
president she's next in line how do you
how do you rationalize passing her by if
Joe doesn't run how can you get away
with passing her by she's you got to
pull the race card you have to do it
identity politics so you so you replace
a woman of color with a far more popular
two women the country I'm out no not
necessarily but I I don't think that
they can I mean you can't just bypass
Camala Harris despite the fact that she
doesn't have dementia but she makes less
sense than
you uh so but how how do they convin
like what does he say after much
consideration with my family I've
realized that during these difficult
times I'm just uh demented like how does
it work uh his health will not just just
won't allow it his health won't allow it
he doesn't look well or what everyone's
been saying is B and the document I mean
and you said this Pro on the unusual
suspects the document thing is still
kind of lingering they could always go
to that I here's a Telltale sign that
they're in trouble when you have people
with Trump derangement syndrome like
Michael Rapaport losing his mind and
cardi B can you understand cardi B can't
even speak English she's going live with
all her fans remember she was
interviewing Trump and she's like I like
you like politics no interviewing Biden
interviewing Biden back in the day they
interviewed her twice and now she for
you know it's bad Pat when people like
her are starting to turn you know 100%
Joe Biden you already nailed it there's
no way he's running it's yeah let's see
what C has
political she knows what she's talking
about the context for this clip is that
there's $100 million in cuts to Social
Services and other programs in New York
and that's why she is against she's
getting involved yeah before we play
this the context was Eric Adams mayor of
New York said I'm having so much trouble
and so much cost with all this
immigration that's landing on here I
need the federal government to help help
and if I don't get the federal
government to help I am going to lay off
these people cut this cut this cut this
so Eric Adams was trying to Blackmail
the federal government into sending
taxpayer money to help him and this is
the response from a citizen and and and
and before he play and it was time he
was going to less uh get rid of cops and
get rid of $1 billion do for Education
that whole basket of threat yep for not
this why I'm telling you I'm not this
year don't [__] ask me I don't give a
[__] the resume day they
I don't give a [__] I'm not endorsing no
[__] president no more cuz how is
that aund $100 million budget cut in New
York City for for um she's trying to
read [__] schools Library uh police
safety and sanitation yeah Joe Biden is
talking about like yeah we could fund
two Wars we could fund two Wars
[__] talking about we don't got
it but we got it like we're the greatest
nation no the [__] we're not we're going
through some [__] right now say it
really finally woke up she's a non
interventionist she's the singer that's
saying WAP right yeah her WAP is about
to get dried up right now because guess
what there goes there goes the country
that you ass
president I got that wet ass let see
what uh let's see what rap report said
go go ahead look at this freaking psycho
down to Pig dick Donald
Trump and smoking Joe
Biden I'm
sorry I am
sorry voting for pig dick Donald Trump
Trump pink is on the table I'm sorry
uhoh I'm [__] I'll still call him
slob dick Donald Trump what a p dick
Donald Trump and all that Trump the
rangement syndrome big time but we need
to get this whole [__] situation
under control oh but guess what too late
and and and this is Pat and this is what
drives me crazy we told you like that
this is this is what Trump Arrangement
syndrome do where the personality you
didn't like the coddling and the rubbing
of your head while you were getting
screwed over it now I'm I'm happy to see
this hang listen to what he says there
at the very end what does he say we have
to get control listen to what Roger was
just saying and you can see the plan
inside the conventions are very
different Hillary tried to gain game the
super delegates as part of her strategy
it wasn't a natural primary remember how
she looked so calm cool and collected
not worry about polling and things they
were doing as candidate Junior senator
from Illinois Barack Obama who had done
a great speech at the previous DNC
suddenly is gaining momentum you saw
that's that's how it works that's where
it's coming from Roger I'm with you I
think what's going to happen we're going
to get to the convention somebody's
going to say Joe the super delegant are
moving the other way you're going to get
the pardon you got to Pardon your son
you got to get the stuff out of the way
that's going to be messy for us and
we're done I believe it happens with the
superdelegate manipulation at the
convention is that Bingo Bingo but but
Gavin Newsome who's very I think
effectively advertising his availability
you cannot replace the the woman vice
president of color with a white male you
just can't do that so he gets to be vice
president on Michelle tiet do why do me
because the Dynamics of their party will
not allow who gives a [__] you're going
to lose the most woke you think that
this woke ass left is going to let cuz
you know what they're going to say you
let a white man take over are you crazy
he's more
capable Donna Donna Brazil goes I'm with
Roger Donna Brazil and others go nuclear
if you try to do that she's the one
here's what's going to happen here's
what's going to happen I mean the the
the guy uh Mee if you read what he said
he said if you're uh on the left and you
molest another journalist as long as you
support pro-abortion they'll hide it y
if you're this and you do that as long
as you support their green deal they'll
hide it but God forbid if you're on the
opposite side they want to kill you they
will destroy you right okay
okay Andrew Kom is by far one of the
best case studies Co starts first six
months this guy would have been a better
president than Donald Trump he's this
he's that he's this flag and then you
look at Andrew and you see somebody
that's probably not going to be a yes
man to Schumer to Nancy to Obama to any
of these guys and then all of a sudden
like wait a minute I'm convinced he
wasn't listening to what he was doing
and what they were asking him to do they
said okay you want to do this do you
forget what we have on you we will
destroy your life and guess what they
did they did they did not the right the
left did it to themselves they eat their
own so guess what's going to happen they
have a book the size of a Bible with
enough ways to destroy Biden that one's
going to be an easy phone call to make
but they don't want to get to that point
they wanted to be a nice friendly one to
get to Biden and they have W as well
with Kamala that they can destroy her as
well and that one's going to be a little
bit complicated because I think she'll
fight it I think she'll fight it a
little bit like Andrew kwood when they
try to do that with her eventually she's
going to have to come out then at that
point they'll pick whoever it's going to
be but by the way it's it's the DNC is
when it's August of next year in Chicago
correct the RNC is July of next year I
want to say in Milwaukee if I'm not
mistaken yeah so I know the next debate
coming up December 6th is is in B but
they going to do Milwaukee as the uh RNC
they don't want to have a lot of time
left okay they don't have a lot of time
left if they're going to make their
moves they got to make their moves
fairly quickly to get that guy out and
when I say guy I mean Biden I think the
hard one's going to be camalo well first
of all they'll be looking at the polling
between the two conventions Trump will
get a bounce out of his convention
that'll scare the crap out of them even
more
secondarily Cala is not that difficult
to solve you want to be on the US
Supreme Court good all you got to do is
Step Aside we win the election we win
the Senate you are the Attorney General
of California you can be on the Supreme
Court they buy her out and she goes
quietly that's my guess wow I don't know
if she's going to it's going to be the
easiest campaign for the r to run with
easiest campaign they say they for women
they told her to sit in the back of the
bus they say they're for blacks they
told her to do this all talk no action
don't trust the Democrats they only want
your vote but once you vote for them
they won't do what they say they'll do
for face
Joe keeps making this easy for them by
by being Joe I mean running from the
from the turkey part like cuz he I think
he crapped his pants me yeah looked like
looked like uh not knowing where to put
the wreath at the soldier I mean the
more This Guy's in public the more
dysfunctional he appears that just that
just fuels uh this this Rob he's he's on
he's at the White House on the White
House lawn and I guess the turkey just
came out this 100 tradition the
President part and he has to take a poop
this is I got to go take a poop watch
this hey look at that hey guys I got to
just J no like how embarrassing is this
guy look they're not they're not even
done coming out yet look at this he's
gone is this when did this happen
yesterday he just was like I got to go
take a crap he left everybody on the
lawn I don't know about all that what do
you mean he did they there's a million
other Clips we could to play that are
way worse than that I'll tell you is one
every day that's the point yeah no doubt
but if we can go to that general
election stat that Pat kicked us off
with that's scary I agree but that's not
the scariest stat that we've seen in the
last week or so so what was that 46
44 no not that not that one the initial
one the scariest thing with Roger
alluded to initially is the Battleground
States and the swing States there's five
states that dictate basically what's
going to happen this election Roger
knows this better than anybody we know
that California New York is voting blue
we know that Alabama and Tennessee are
voting red that's not even a question
4644 we know that the election's going
to come down to the you know it's a too
close to call we already seen this a
million times comes down to five states
and these are the polls this is um New
York Times and Sienna College not
exactly uh rightwing exactly credible
methodology Trump versus Biden Nevada
swing state Trump's up 10 10 Georgia up
six Arizona up five Michigan up five
Pennsylvania up four those are the
states you got to pay attention to and
if Trump's in all big in those five
states
this thing's done but R what do you
Roger what do you think okay do you
think what's happening in New York is
enough to stick because the left is
always up to something R like we're not
stupid I know I know you you get it we
spoke about this uh the other day what
is what they have on Trump enough to
make him not run uh there's no
circumstance whatsoever under which he
does not run none if and if he he said
this if he has to run from a prison cell
he will as long as he's not convicted of
a crime that makes him ineligible to be
on the bot or eligible to be president
uh and if they martyr him they might
even make him stronger that is certainly
been it's counterintuitive but that's
what's happened so far these
prosecutions of him have turbocharged
his campaign and I think I think that
Trend will continue Roger what's your
relationship with Trump at this point I
know you've been a surrogate you've been
an advocate said very good I saw him two
Fridays ago talk to him night before
last you guys have known each other how
long 45 years wow and uh what's his just
overall you know tenure how's he doing
what's he's surprisingly confident I
mean this guy is got ice water in his
veins I me he look I work for Nixon I
work for Dole they're very very tough
guys Trump is the toughest guy I've ever
met I mean he he he really just lets it
roll down his back I mean under the kind
of pressure that he's in he's he's
Resolute he's determined he is a little
angry but Maggie haberman's right about
that but I think he has every right to
be angry but he's not unhinged he's not
hysterical he's not depressed he's he's
really in a surprisingly good mood uh
and he's absolutely convinced that he
will win he's absolutely convinced that
whatever they throw at him he can handle
when you heard things like he's thin
skinned and he's like a man baby what's
the reality of I have not I've never
experienced that and I spent a lot of
time with him I traveled with him now
about a month and a half ago for 4 days
and I was surprised at how you can you
can be in a situation 20 years ago walk
away from it and come back and
everything is exactly the same it's
exactly the same so Bill Mar says Trump
is beating Biden because he would Clean
Cities Bill Maher attributed Trump's
polling success over Biden to the
perception that Trump would take
proactive measures to address
deteriorating cities Mar uh humorously
pointed out the temporary nature of San
Francisco cleanup efforts stating put
aside the fact that you can clean up the
with company coming over he elaborated
when he talks I'm going to put us put
people in camps the immigrants all this
kind of stuff and people just see a
place a country especially in those
cities that look out of control down to
Brazil and Adam kinzinger guess on a
marshall concurred with Mars's
assessment anyways uh Brazil emphasized
that people clean up when something
different happens and raise questions
about finding long-term Solutions
particularly with homeless individuals
the reality of it is right
now if this guy comes back and he
wins and AR Ina did what they did Italy
had it a couple years ago more and more
people are just kind of going to leave
me alone I kind of want to build my life
I don't want to be controlled the way I
am if it happens in America I I think
this is going to be a very weird
entertaining four years if Trump wins
again if he wins it is so early it's
second quarter with you know five
minutes left it's not even halftime yet
would you agree it's second quarter with
five minutes left yes and and in
politics a week is a lifetime a week and
things can change very dramatically do
we have an a terrorist attack on
American soil against American interests
that would change things uh let's pray
not no obviously but it's a very real
possibility we have let several the open
borders millions and millions of people
into the country that we can't even
identify we know there's 128 people on
the FBI's list how many got through that
that we didn't catch so it's going to be
a tumultuous 12 months here uh and uh
all of those events can change
everything what's the likelihood that
the Democratic party will just go down
with the ship like if you see because I
watched that whole Meet the Press when
they did um all those stats and
everything like that they had um Senator
Blumenthal from Connecticut on and he
basically was like she asked him uh
Kristen Welker do you think that Joe
Biden is still the um best candidate yes
I believe that Joe Biden is still the
best candidate so he still has his
Advocates out there in the Senate who
are basically saying yeah yeah no he's
still our guy what's the likelihood
they're just that's it they see all the
numbers they see the polling and they're
like nope we're rolling with Biden I I
think it's unlikely I really do uh he's
uh he's playing the he's playing the
inside game but he doesn't really
believe that he's just saying it kind of
because he has to uh but I really think
the handwriting is on the wall I think
they recognize if they renominate Biden
there's a high probability they lose uh
they don't understand the toxic mix they
have of riseing crime the fentanyl
crisis the cities all now and States now
all being broke because we have to spend
for social services for this influx of
illegal migrants uh mixed messaging in
the in the Middle East where we appear
to be on both sides funding both sides a
hundred billion dollar more for Iran
this is this is a death wish this is
insanity election when you think about
you know these guys were able to count
99.4% of all the votes in Argentina
okay and it took us 40 days 30 days
whatever the timeline is to vote weird
is that weird whether you're left right
centered doesn't like you how the hell
did a country like
Argentina how were they able to count as
many votes as they did as quickly as
they did and America can't do it we are
supposed to be the leaders of the Free
World how is that possible because
because it's purposeful they they have
paper ballots in France they counted 38
million votes in one day it can be done
but it's it's instructive that no state
certainly none of the Swing states have
had any significant reform in their El
state election laws that will govern the
next presidential election since the
last presidential election with the one
exception there was a challenge to
mailin ballots uh in Pennsylvania uh as
being unconstitutional they clearly are
I mean it's very specifically uh laid
out in the Constitution the lower courts
knock them out the middle courts Ain the
lower courts the state supreme court
which is extremely political reinstated
them so we're going to have mail and
ballots in Pennsylvania again in all
honesty I question whether you can win
Pennsylvania as a republican as long as
you have mail and ballot the
Philadelphia machine is pretty famous at
their ability to manipulate these so um
will we have there's two questions here
can Trump win yes he most definitely win
can win meaning will there be enough
votes to be a majority but will we have
a free Fair honest transparent election
in which everyone has confidence I think
that's still an open question Roger one
more for you if you don't mind uh you've
been around politics for better half of
40 years right what will a second Trump
presidency look like you have an inside
relationship you know what's going on
what would that actually look like for
the country I think it'll be a pretty
radical it'll be a pretty radical
presidency first of all Dwight
Eisenhower uh deported 1.3 illegals we
have got to to take these people who
entered the country illegally and we
have to deport them it's not it's not
unreasonable they're not has he told you
he wants to do that he said it publicly
he doesn't need to tell me I mean he's
announced it uh well public statements
are different than what he actually
tells someone that he actually is
friends but but but he he he has said it
uh he would reform uh you know our
intelligence agencies he would certainly
reform our law enforcement agencies uh I
he does these long form policy videos
but because they're up on true social
they don't get the kind of currency that
they should get because they're very
detailed and they're very well thought
out and these presentation's quite good
but they they don't get the kind of
attention they deserve but he's on
virtually every issue he's put out
detailed positions uh I urge people to
watch them I got a couple stories I want
to get to before we get into uh johnf
Kennedy 6 year anniversary coming up
tomorrow Sean Colmes and singer Cassie
set a lawsuit I think it took 24 hours
record-breaking how quickly this was hip
hop mogul Diddy and singer Cassie ventur
have reached a settlement the abuse
lawsuit filed by Ventura the terms of
the settlement have not been disclosed
Ventura had accused comes of using drugs
and alcohol to control her during the
decade long relationship alleging
physical abuse and force sexual acts
with male prostitutes including an
alleged rape in 2018 Combs lawyer has
called these claims outrageous lies the
lawsuit also lists several of com's
businesses as defendants and combs known
as Puff Daddy p and Diddy as a long
history music industry and businessman
including his Sean John clothing line
Vinnie what are your thoughts on this so
um they reported this uh on barel Sports
I saw something where they actually put
all the court documents out there so
just to give you guys a little heads up
of why he settled and it was so fast uh
in the court documents he has uh she she
alleged that he had severe rage issues
he would beat he would regularly beat
her give her black eyes fat lips kick
her in the face kick her in the stomach
uh he would hire male escorts that would
all wear masks he'd give them all
cocaine ecstasy ketamine just to name a
few and he would have them all perform
sexual acts her with them while he
watched masturbated and filmed it okay
so no wonder why he doesn't want this
out he also beat her so bad once in the
hallway of the Intercontinental Hotel
that he paid $50,000 cash to the hotel
to obtain the footage which is what a
great Hotel because they're helping you
cover up uh your your your shitty
attitude uh now that we've been told
that in the past like think about this
we've been told believe all women right
Adam we talked about this the last time
that this was mentioned and hold their
abusers accountable apparently that's
true unless you pay the person you pay
the female a lot of money then it all
all goes away here's my question Pat
what what kind of standards are we
teaching the younger women like find a
man who's rich he's famous he's powerful
if he beats the hell out of you forces
you to have sex with people and do
orgies and take all these drugs that's
fine just hold on to it cuz one day just
like what happened with her it pays off
if they're true if there're actually
true and provable allegations shouldn't
he be in jail to hell with the money to
hell with all that what what's the
difference between him Roger than Bill
Cosby or or R Kelly she can prove these
facts this the court this is the court
these are Court these are the court
documents P he he he was drugging her
bringing people to have sex he was
recording it he's doing all this thing
and what as as the As Americans we're
supposed to just go okay he paid her
let's just all Let It Go away like is
that is that that is that what we want
to teach the younger generation and
these younger girls like listen you're
going to get abused he's going to beat
you he's going to do all this stuff he's
going to make you have sex and do drugs
but guess what hold on to it cuz you're
going to get paid in the future I think
this is a shitty shitty way he belongs
in jail if R Kelly's in jail and Bill
Cosby got arrested he belongs in jail
those guys both went to trial they both
had trials in this country you're still
innocent till proven guilty those are
still allegations shocking yes but this
matter is not going to go to court maybe
he doesn't want to go to court for a lot
of reasons I'll say this there's nothing
in his clothing line that I would be
willing
to what do you think
I like this one ran out of his apartment
with a firearm in pursuit of a rival
industry executive who he learned was
nearby ladies and gentlemen in the world
of Hip Hop that's called negotiation
yeah so Adam CU you blew up a man's car
did you miss that yeah he blew up what's
it yeah he B the guy was scared about he
was threatened to blow up his car and
actually blew up cuz Adam last week you
mentioned you were like ah this whole
believe all women she's just trying to
get money I get it I I don't think that
this is the case when she has all this
information all these allegations and as
him not to want it to go to court yeah I
think we if we've learned anything over
the last uh since basically 2017 in the
me too movement that there's probably a
gray area in between here of course it's
not black and white it's not like he's
all bad she's all good we saw Jing
Johnny Depp turns out Amber herd was a
[__] [__] and liar yeah okay we all
know what's going on with Andrew Tate
it's an absolute travisty we see what's
happening with Russ a big difference
here's a difference what the difference
is Johnny Depp said let's go to cour and
bring in the cameras yeah Diddy is
saying no no no let's not go to cour I
don't want the cameras in the room man
un like Johnny and no doubt again but
that everything that happened with
Russell bran
but do I think that Diddy was doing some
wild ass [__] for sure punching her in
the face and beating her that's a whole
different situation disgusting Horrible
no man should ever put his hands on a
woman whatsoever y but here's the next
question why didn't she leave
why didn't she leave some she she's got
money okay she was a Hip-Hop star you
know early 2000s why did she stay that's
my question I got like if a guy's
beating you get the [__] out of there
girl let's EAS yourself what some some
of these girls have that what's that
syndrome where they stay with the abuser
Stockholm syndrome they but I think I
think I don't know if that's what's
going on here I don't think that that's
the question in a situation like this
it's holding somebody like that cuz he's
an evil he seems like an evil piece of
[__] and that's not only the ru words
it's keeping him accountable look at all
the like if that you know you know what
keeps him accountable Vinnie are the
courts and they settled so it's over
well they say they settle but I she
didn't have to settle she didn't have to
settle yes she didn't have to settle but
what I'm saying she's going have said
[__] you I'm not taking your offer I'm
not settling and they could have gone to
court but she settled yeah she want yeah
cuz guess what she wants compensation
for everything that he's done exactly
she's getting it I still think settling
is one thing but holding him accountable
so why don't you call Cassie and say
listen let me be your trial attor
let's take this to criminal court and
let me handle this what's your point
though what's that she settled just
don't you don't need to scream what's
your point with s fired up I know you
are I just the audio is high so so
what's your point with settling tell me
well so the point you're making so this
was a Civil Trial this wasn't a criminal
trial right so a Civil Trial is what
over money over property over emotional
damage she has like P you're saying what
you're saying his evil because he's
settle fast you're saying why are you
you settling if it's that important to
you why are you taking the money corre
okay I get you yeah it's good points she
for $30 million she got somewhere
between Z $30 million she named her
price she got it she's done great and I
will you know I I agree a part of it is
you're 19 years old she's helping him
get the career going at that time Diddy
is Diddy I mean he's bigger than what he
is today he helped her get her career
going sorry yeah he helped her get the
he was 37 she was 19 seen the clip of
him running into Studio from Studio to
Studio to studio and he runs in and and
Cassie's there recording you haven't
seen this one very interesting Clips are
going all over the place with what he
was doing this is a very interesting guy
very interesting guy that he is and the
the the the most fascinating part about
this is while this is happening how many
people came out defending did he zero I
he I haven't heard one person come out
and say I mean you get one or two three
or four or five zero you're right used
to date JLo in 20 they by the way they
asked JLo about what it was like to
dating Diddy you should see how she
speaks she speaks as if she's speaking
sign language oh really and you know she
she says I wasn't mature enough I had to
really uh I wasn't ready for a
relationship like that because back then
I really didn't value myself like it
wasn't like you know anyways listen I'm
not I'm not a fan of a um
anybody I talk to nobody has good things
to say about that no and and how many
dude and trust me I've I've heard way
crazier you know allegations and stuff
like that about him but Adam when you
said why why didn't she leave so she was
19 years old with a 37y old Superstar
that's kind of you know but it's not
like they dated for 6 months vny they
were together 10 years yeah but when
they start dating her she's a grownup at
this point not at 19 years old Adam she
exactly so it started then but it's not
like they had a two- Monon stint they're
together 10 years so meaning she was 19
until she she's basically 30 so it's not
like she's some child that couldn't make
her own decisions is if he's hitting her
that's horrible never do that to a woman
if he's drugging her doing this weird
ass [__] zero zero advocacy for that but
she needs to say you know what I don't
care that this guy's a full-on
billionaire I don't care that this guy
made my career I'm out let's transition
out to an important story new study
reveals one in four remote workers are
sneaking off to have sex while on the
job yeah it just came out where Tom
extremely uh uh interesting by the way
you know who story this is you know
whose story this is Fox News okay go
figure what P this 18 a recent study by
calendar Labs revealed that 26% of
remote workers workers in the US are
engaging in sexual activities during
work hours with researchers noting as
remote work becomes more common it
tracks that scheduled intimacy extends
into workplace for some who work from
home remote workers have been using
emojis like sandwich headphones or fire
to deceive colleagues and bosses leading
them to believe they're occupied with
work related tasks while they are
actually having sex the trend is
unlimited to remote workers as one in 10
office workers have also found
opportunities for sexual encounters at
work the study highlights that scheduled
intimacy correlates with higher
relationships satisfaction with 49% of
those who plan ahead reporting higher
overall satisfaction and better intimacy
for fillment compared to those who don't
Vinnie I listen if you we were talking
about this maybe this might be helping
the fact that we're not having enough
enough babies but like like you have to
you have to put a you have to put a
sandwich and be like if you're at home
pal what do you think people are do it's
not it's not only that they're doing
other stuff you know what I mean I it
kind of explains why you and Brady
always running off to lunch the middle
of the day yeah you know wait what well
listen we all know that you get a job
for money for income but also benefits
mhm what comes with the benefits you get
you know Insurance you get your 401k
maybe there's a profit sharing plan and
maybe you get a little uh sexy time
during lunch I think it works out well
for employees what do you think Raj
where do I sign
up Raj
Stone want to work from home anybody
working from home well we saw some
economic reports that said 33% of
America were worried about getting laid
off and then 22% are just wored getting
laid off laid off and 22% are just
worried about getting laid so it's like
excuse me what was the question but uh
you know Pat you've told some wild ass
stories about what you've seen in your
day these two these two these two have
been I came in the office at a Sunday
the they've been working very hard
you've built a company with 30,000 plus
insurance agents A lot of them are
couples you've dealt with a lot of this
stuff before I really wonder like this
work from home phenomenon like that
these young Generations deceived some of
these companies that fell for this trap
like a I work harder at home than I do
at the office who the hell believes that
you're an independent contractor you
work $ 1099 you're a consultant whatever
it is what it is we got plenty of them
and I've been in that space for you know
what do you call it 20 years but you got
W2 full-timers working from home
claiming they're more efficient at home
than they are at the office it took
three years to realize that was an
absolute myth now this may be a another
reason why they may be selling the
benefits of working from home exactly
and uh who knows whether it's going to
work for their favor or not you guys
know where I stand when it comes on to
this okay all right next story is teen
boys are falling for a Snapchat nud
photo scam here's how to avoid it this
is a Wall Street Journal story okay
parents listen up it's a worthy story
for you to see what's going on here with
SNAP so scammers are targeting teen boys
in an online nude photo scam posing as
teen girls to solicit explicit photos
from the boys and then demanding money
via peer-to-peer payment apps
threatening to share their photos if
they don't pay the national Center for
missing and exploited children have seen
a significant increase in reports of
this type of financial extortion with
over 12,500 cases this year reported
Snapchat's parent company conducted a
survey revealing that 65% of respondents
or their friends have been targeted
targeted in schemes where attackers
obtain explicit personal imagery and
threaten to release it most the victims
or boys parents and teens can take
preventative measures including
educating teens about such scams
advising them to engage with strangers
requesting explicit content protecting
their social media accounts and
supervising payment apps Tom look you
know what this is this is a failure in
parenting that phone that computer that
laptop is not a babysitter for your kids
this is a failure of parenting because
you know what you know Predators have
have been around forever there was the
playground predators predators that were
offing kids candy and trying to cono
them and then they would go off and
exploit them and worse and you just have
your parents here parents and schools
need to work together because in the
digital world here this is what's going
on and what they're not talking about in
this is we we have seen statistics on
suicides of girls under 16 that are
relating to being cornered or shamed and
being terribly fearful
and so I I think what's going on here
you need to know what your kids are
doing what we do and I'll give you a tip
here and I saw a talk on this I wasn't
born with this information but God Bless
the people put it together I teach my
girls to reason and resist to reason
with what's going on first of all
Foundation of what's right and wrong
don't put yourself in this position but
to reason when you encounter people and
things that look weird and people are
approaching you and stuff and to resist
the temptation to be included and to
resist you know
things like social media where I don't
know what good happens on social media
but I I this is this is this is
Downstream from parenting absent
parenting and Upstream decisions like
letting your kids just use that phone
and use that iPad and use that PC all
day what are they doing they're going to
these sites and professionals are
getting to them Tom let me ask you a
follow up on that pbd as well and Rob
you have got you've got a teenage boy so
I it's pretty I don't have any kids I I
uh have a nephew who's 10 years old but
the the the parenting game has changed
you know when we were raised what were
they saying like you know don't get into
strangers cars yeah you know don't take
candy from strangers it was basically
like go out play do your thing just
don't talk to random ass strangers now
all the strangers are on the internet
yeah okay and they're hitting you up and
they're doing all this weird ass stuff
and parents are haven't been trained for
this you know when did the Internet even
become popular as far as social media
goes 2010 2012 maybe before that a
little bit with Facebook so what steps
can parents take especially if there's
no parenting social media class or they
haven't been raised on this stuff what
what can parents do to basically un what
do you call it uh resist and reason and
resist reason and resist what's your
message for parents out there my message
for parents and and I like to hear what
Roger thinks about this distracted youth
have been an issue for a long time when
TV really exploded and it was more than
just soap operas on in the afternoon
people are like don't let your kids just
sit there and watch TV all day you know
that's not the way to distract them but
the TV wasn't dming you no but it was
the point is there's been distraction
versus productive things number one
engaging with your kids number two
knowing what they're engaging with
number three encouraging them and
rewarding them for things like reading
and getting grades in school and you
know look we know how to manage
companies Whatever Gets measured gets
managed it's an amazing thing you know
people that want a bonus or a promotion
whatever you manage suddenly they
cooperate and do things you change your
bonus structure hey we the company has
to hit a certain Revenue we have to have
a certain profit and if the company gets
a profit then we pay you suddenly
everybody's very interested every month
on how the company's doing on profit
because they want their bonus but I I
think I think it it starts it starts
there are you engaged with your kids
lives and are you giving them incentives
to do the good things Roger uh parents
and grandparents are using uh the cell
phone the computer as a babysitter and
they're not monitoring what their kids
are looking at I I have three young
grandchildren my kids watch very
carefully what their kids are are
looking at uh and they and they use some
of the programs to block you know
certain certain apps and so on uh I
think it's just a total absence of
parent responsibility it's like kids
leave me alone go go go go look at the
computer it's like they're using as
babysitters it's very dangerous yeah and
and by the way awareness education is
the key to all of this stuff uh there's
a movie I recommend every parent to
watch uh husband wife watch it first
before you want to show it to your kids
because it's pretty dark it's called
disconnect uh with Jason baitman if
you've never seen it go watch this movie
as soon as possible it'll tell you the
Dark Side of what's going on right now
and how kids are being affected by this
okay um What story do we want to go
let's go to the story and then we'll
wrap it up with uh uh I think I'll
combine these two together so Elon
musk's ex advertisement nightmare
companies that have boycotted the app
and it is not slowing down right now if
you can go to page 15 here we go so Elon
Musk is facing major boy from companies
and government bodies that are from uh
after endorsing an allegedly
anti-semitic post onx musk respond to a
post that seemed to promote an
anti-semitic conspiracy theory sparked
backlash major companies including Apple
IBM European commission Disney Paramount
Sony Pictures Warner Brothers sky and
NBC Universal owner Comcast have
suspended advertising on xon's response
to musk's controversial remarks Media
Matters reported that ads from Big
Brands were appearing alongside pro-nazi
content on the platform the white house
condemned musk's promotion of
anti-Semitism semitism and musk respond
by vowing to protect free speech on X
claiming Media Matters Mis
misrepresentative platform's user
experience and accusing them of uh
trying to undermine freedom of speech
Tom uh first of all I find it very
interesting how the media has lined up
100% against the guy that was trying to
put uh free speech out there and not
just cancel accounts and take them off
Twitter very interesting Disney
Paramount Sony Pictures Warner Brothers
Sky NBC Universal and its owner Comcast
that's interesting interesting all the
people that've been very frustrated that
they can't force x and Twitter to cancel
a lot of conservative and moderate
voices interesting and then Apple and
IBM joining look was it the best um post
that Elon Musk has made this year no is
it at a very inflammable time that's
going on right now yes but I look also
to to what Elon mus said in a more
extended you know a segment from an
interview where he was explaining what
was going on and I think he was very
clear about it and I think people are
choosing to be inflamed about this
because he's a Target in the first place
well and and uh based on the lawsuit he
filed in Texas yesterday Media Matters
has basically manipulated this so what
they claim is not even true uh it's an
extraordinary lawsuit how coincidental
that the head of all those companies are
the same people who met with chairman X
in St Francisco last week how incredibly
coincidental Elon Musk there are very
very few people who can say that they
changed the course of history Elon Musk
is one of those few people his his
acquisition of Twitter uh and his
Revelations about the manipulation of
Twitter under the previous ownership
have literally changed the course of
history well the I'm sort of a uh Free
Speech absolutist right like unless it's
inciting violence I would say go ahead
and say it I can't tell you how much Jew
hatred I've gotten
um even before the Hamas Israel war and
it's disgusting it's horrible but I'm a
grown ass man I'd rather hear all the
negativity uh online and okay cool this
is what I'm dealing with rather than
they're saying it amongst themselves and
be by the way whether it's Jew hatred
whether it's racist stuff whether it's
anti-arab stuff islamophobia anti-lgbt
people are going to say their [__]
whatever they have it's horrible it's
disgusting but you know
it's not only do I defend your right to
say it even I defend your right to say
it even if it hurts my feelings and I
think we're at a point in this country
where feelings are getting hurt and
that's fine and as long as you don't
call for violence which some are by the
way uh I I think it's in within your
right to say it even though it's
disgusting well I feel pretty strong
about this because I'm banned for life
on Facebook I'm banned for life on
Instagram I'm banned for life on YouTube
uh I'm obviously the most dangerous
person uh in the world by the way there
is somebody on Facebook pretending be me
uh I've had several people who are
members including my wife complained
about it he's he's got 6,500 followers
which is pretty good but he is not me
they won't take it down so uh no I I
think what musk has done is really
courageous uh and the political as uh
aspects of it the fact that our
intelligence agencies were leaning on
the company to to censor certain
profiles certain people certain messages
Hunter Biden's laptop and so on this has
really kind of changed our politics in a
in a very very substantial way and I
would point out to you now the B
Administration is has put forward
regulations for the FCC to regulate
content on the internet so we're now
going to go above the social media
program uh platforms to try to get
censorship at that level it's extra it's
unconstitutional it's extraordinarily
dangerous here's what Sasha Baron Cohen
told Tik Tok leaders he said they are
creating the biggest anti-Semitic
movement since the Nazis uh by the way
and this is a left-wing Jewish celebrity
Sasha Baron Cohen expressed concerns
during a private uh call with Tik Tok
leaders about the platform's role on
spreading anti-Semitism Cohen criticized
Tik Tok stating what is happening on Tik
Tok is it is creating the biggest
anti-semitic movement since the Nazis
Deborah Messing known for her role in
Will and Grace emphasized that Tik Tok a
china-owned company has become the main
platform from dis dis dissemination of
je hat she pointed to the pro uh to the
use of the slogan from The River To The
Sea and question Tik tok's policy on
addressing
anti-emetic content look you know on one
end you have one argument with uh
Twitter on the other end you have
another argument with Tik Tock uh what
are your thoughts for yourself from what
Sasha is saying here I mean it's true uh
you see what's going on out there and uh
yeah it's it's sad but I mean I just
kind of addressed this before I I look I
grow up I I'm come in Miami it's a
Melting Pot I friends with Jewish people
Catholic people Christian people
Hispanic people black people Asian
people Jamaican Haitian the whole thing
and I've never dealt with any of this
like the first time I ever dealt with
Jew hatred was when I went to played
college football in North Carolina and I
told this actually a funny story and uh
all the all the um I I basically didn't
practice on yum kipor which is basically
the holiest day of the Jewish and I'm
not very religious but I'm I believe in
Tradition I believe in uh my culture and
I told the coach I said hey I can't
practice today it's yum kapor and this
is like he was like a 75y old white guy
North Carolina he's never I don't think
even seen a Jew he goes uh yum
what I said uh yum Kor the day of
atonement it's kind of like kind of like
Easter for Christians uh a yum what boy
get out there put your pads on we got to
get practice we got a big game this
Sunday this Saturday I'm like uh yeah I
can't I I'm not allowed to eat today I'm
not like but I'm here I'll just watch
practice boy I didn't want to hear what
this yum Kipper thing is all about here
boy just you know what you know what put
on your pads walk around and pick up
trash yeah I was like really I got
topper got to go pick up trash on yum
Kipper and I was just like all right
this guy's never been around Georgia
it's fine so I picked up trash no big
deal but since that since that time all
my teammates started calling me Brew uh
short for Hebrew I love that I was like
this this school's awesome so uh didn't
spend much time there transferred to
Florida state did my thing there but I
I've realized that you like what Jews
are what 1% of America 0.1% of the world
yet we're the we're the cause of all the
world's problems it's sort of obnoxious
to me and Jews have dealt with this
since uh eternity and they've been
scapegoated throughout history whether
it's in Egypt whether it's the Spanish
Inquisition whether it's Nazi Germany or
whether it's what's going on today and
you know I I'm I'm I guess in a sense
Zionist where I do believe that Jews
need a home and a safe space and that is
now called modern day Israel and even
that is the nicest place in the worst
neighborhood in the world and uh it's
sad to see what's going on but um Jews
they have as Jews we have a phrase that
has basically culminated since the
Holocaust which is never again uh people
want to exterminate us famously they say
if uh people of Palestine put on put
down all their guns there will be peace
if the people of Israel put down their
guns they will all be massacred so the
Jews have had to build up the IDF and
the mad and build up a defense mechanism
not to be slaughtered for the sake that
they are just Jews so for me uh I'm not
the most religious person you know I'm
not going to Temple or church like you
guys are going every Sunday but I do
understand what's going on in the world
right now and it's sad to see and people
need to speak out about it so Sasha
Baron con good for you and I and and I
think the the Elon thing is ridiculous
Media Matters is a complete shitty
horrible like I I Media Matters sucks
this is the question was about Tik Tock
and you know that's a China owned
company how they they're pushing the
lgbtq on on the Youth hold on hard
hardcore they have all these challenges
Pat that make the youth do what tide pod
challenges to just lighting yourself on
fire challenges they're brainwashing the
youth they're being anti- like and but
here's the thing Adam what do they China
could do whatever they want didn't Trump
try to say that he wanted to get rid of
yeah Tik Tok we were at the RNC debate I
don't know if you were there in Miami uh
I know I was in high at the Trump R the
Trump rally
respect CH China can do whatever they
want and guess what it's it's out there
you can see what they're doing that
Sasha Bor knows what's up but what are
you gonna do China could do bro China
comes to San Francisco they grab all the
homeless and kick them out and somebody
told said this the other day P where are
those homeless people apparently like
they're they disappeared all the people
in those streets apparently there was
Vans driving around Roger picking them
up putting them in the Vans and getting
rid of them they haven't come back where
are those thousands of homeless people
that were in San Francisco you ever
notice that gone but again the most
outrageous part of this is Media Matters
America which is a smear operation
accusing Elon Musk of anti-Semitism on
the basis of manipulated uh stuff on the
site is complete
[__] he is most definitely not an
anti-a it's a bum rap it's a smear yeah
guy that's trying to save the human race
is racist towards one get out give me a
guy is worth $300 billion can buy
countries small countries if he wants to
and he's going to go out there and do
what he's doing here any people let's
wrap it up with let's wrap it up with uh
the 6E anniversary tomorrow John F
Kennedy assassination I've had a lot of
different people on Roger on this topic
you've written a book on it a New York
Times bestselling book the man who
killed Kennedy the case against LBJ I
had a guy on uh the podcast uh I
interviewed him six years ago Jim
Jenkins Rob if you can pull this up when
I was interviewing Jim Jenkins I asked
him a question uh he was one of the four
people in the room that held um johnf
Kennedy's brain okay Jim Jenkins and we
released this interview on could have
been the one of the anniversary dates
and a video was taken down for 6 hours
it was trending in a very good way and
then it was came back up the next day
and I said who out of all the people you
know who do you think was behind it this
is a guy that's been away for 50 years
he was in the military was in the Navy
doesn't want any attention doesn't do
any interviews doesn't talk to anybody
somehow someway we got him to feel
comfortable to come and talk to us and I
had him on the on the show and his wife
was sitting right next to me they've
been married for 50 plus years he says
the only the one man that makes me feel
very uncomfortable is Lyndon Johnson is
who he said how did you come to the
conclusion that Lyndon Johnson was
behind the assassination of jnf Kennedy
uh basically Richard Nixon told me that
he said that the Warren Commission was
the biggest godamn hoax in American
history uh and uh I had uh I'd always
had my suspicions but the point here is
that everybody who's analyzed the
Kennedy assassination looks at it
through a specific prism so Robert F
Kennedy Jr is right when he says the CIA
is involved uh others are right when
they say organized crime was involved
yet others are right when they say the
FBI was involved the Secret Service Big
Texas oil uh the International Banks but
Lyndon Johnson is the Lynch pen he is
the Nexus to all of those institutions
and individuals and he is the man who
has the most acute interest lynon
Johnson is under federal investigation
in the Bobby Baker Scandal and the Billy
Sal esta scandal Robert Kennedy's begun
telling people he's going to be charged
John Kennedy tells Evelyn Lincoln his
personal secretary on his way to Dallas
on the plane Johnson is being dropped
from the ticket Johnson is a man staring
into the abyss he knows he is going to
prison Drew Pearson the most influential
columnist of the day already has a
column in the can for that Sunday the
day after Kennedy supposed to be in
Dallas nailing Johnson for taking a
bribe for a General Dynamic uh defense
appropriation so Johnson has motive
means and opportunity he's the man who
insists that Kennedy go to to Dallas to
bind up the wounds between the
progressive and bourbon wings of the
democratic party he goes to Kennedy's
hotel room the night before and tries to
change the motorcade seating to put his
hated enemy Senator Ralph Yaro in the
death car with Kennedy and move his
former uh Administrative Assistant
Governor John Connelly to the vice
presidential car Kennedy says no that
defeats the whole purpose of why I'm
here I need to be seen with Connelly the
head of the more conservative wing of
the party uh and in my book I I prove
using eyewitness evidence fingerprint
evidence in deep Texas politics that
Johnson and all these other entities
each of whom has their own motive the
CIA uh about the uh uh the anger over
the uh the b pigs failure the anger over
Kennedy's secret deal to uh to remove
our missiles from turkey and Italy in
the Cuban Missile Crisis uh Big Oil over
the repeal of the text of the oil
depletion allowance uh organized crime
who feels double crossed by JFK because
they financed his election and they
bended arms for him broke arms for him
in Chicago and in Texas in 1960 which he
wins a razor thin Victory so everybody
has a their own individual interest the
banks Kennedy is demanding a silver back
dollar they don't want to go there but
Johnson has a unique relationship with
each one of them and I actually prove
that uh among the fingerprints found on
the cardboard boxes in the Crow's Nest
uh is the fingerprint for a man named
Malcolm MC Wallace uh who was who was
convicted who who's convicted uh in 1951
of murder that's how we have his
fingerprints he murdered a man named uh
uh Douglas uh kinzer uh who was in a
love trial with Johnson's sister and who
was trying to Blackmail Lyndon Johnson
uh he was represented at trial by
Johnson's personal Attorney John kofer
uh and he's the only man in the history
of Texas to be convicted of murder and
get a suspended sentence whereupon he
then goes to work at Tempco a defense
contractor owned by DH bird one of the
financers of of uh Johnson's career and
the owner of the Texas schoolbook
depository building so uh when I asked
Nixon point blank after a couple
cocktails cuz Nixon was very button down
it was very hard to get him to talk you
know retrospectively about anything he
was very forward looking until 9:30
until he had a couple of silver bullets
as he would call them he had a couple
martinis and then he got loquacious and
I said uh I said to him um so Mr
President let me ask you a question who
who really killed John Kennedy he kind
of stared into his martini and and uh he
shuddered and he said well Dallas I said
I'm sorry sir I don't understand he said
let me put to you another way Lyndon and
I both wanted to be president the
difference was I wasn't willing to kill
for it wow there it is he laid it right
out and that was really my inspiration
took me five years to write this book
but that was really my my inspiration
for writing the book uh so when Robert
Kennedy says the CIA did it he's not
wrong uh you know when Sam Jean K's
daughter writes a horrific book it says
that the mob did it she's not wrong I
mean everybody has their own interest
but Johnson has a unique relationship
with each Tom where you at with this
when you hear us because I know you put
a lot of time into this not at the
levels of Roger so I amum I landed where
Roger land because I I I look at you
know the immediacy of impact I look at
you know people say 24 hours I don't
think it was 24 hours I it was 84 hours
Lyndon Johnson was basically um allowing
the military industrial complex to do
what they wanted which was to get more
Federal money to replenish arms and they
were going to use up those arms in
Vietnam so it's literally that's correct
right it's like three and a half days
three and a half days the national
period of mourning is not over and
Lyndon Johnson has greenlit the uh
Vietnam War number one and number two
he's provided assurances to Allan Dulles
of the CIA who ended up on the war
commission who Kennedy had just fired
who Kennedy had just fired because
Kennedy gave the famous quote the CIA
needs to be torn in little pieces and
Scattered to The Winds of History I'm
butchering the quote but that was
essentially a quote correct smashed into
a million pieces and Scattered to the
wind because they had be because they
had betrayed him so the Bay of Pigs
master plan included 29 Panamanian
flagged bombers flown were supposed to
be flown by Cuban Pilots correct uh so
that's that's the air cover for the men
storming the beach unbeknownst to JFK uh
Charles Cable the number two man in the
CIA whose brother Earl just happens to
be the mayor of Dallas uh cancels that
so the the men are now being chopped up
on the beach uh and Curtis lame the the
head of the Air Force head of the Joint
Chiefs uh goes to JFK and says we have
to send in the Air Force well this is a
provocation for war with the Russians
that's exactly what Kennedy agreed to
the Bay of Pigs plan only if it had
plausible Deni ability it was supposed
to look like an indigenous Cuban
Invasion and air coming from a separate
country us so he so he says no the CIA
blames him for the failure he blames
them for the failure so there there is
their motive also and this is the most
controversial thing Kennedy has uh is
being treated by Dr Max Jacobson Dr
Feelgood uh on an early version of
methamphetamine which he thinks he's
taking a blend of enzy and vitamins and
it makes him feel better he's a real
he's a genuine war hero and he's
incredible pain his entire life he's
wearing a back brace he can barely walk
I think this most explains why he's so
horny why he is you know chasing all the
time uh and it also uh he's on steroids
constantly he's on steroid this is who
by the way Jeff pardon me this is who
you're Kennedy on Kennedy if you look at
the Manifest to when Kennedy goes to
Vienna for the summit with Jeff Dr Max
Jacobson uh who is uh who is Doctor to
the Stars he is he is administering his
concoction to Frank Sinatra to Maria CLE
to uh Aristotle oases to Nelson
Rockefeller to uh to Joe dagio to
Marilyn Monroe I mean he he is uh to
Pablo Cals I mean this guy is uh is
pushing drugs and everybody thinks
they're taking an allnatural formula
that makes them feel better Robert
Kennedy learns about this
he gets this substance that Kennedy's
injected he sends it out to the FBI lab
and they tell him what it is and he goes
back to his brother he says you can't
and by this time John Kennedy has Jackie
Kennedy taking it uh and uh sh Robert
Kennedy says to his brother you this is
dangerous you can't be doing this and he
said I don't care if it's horse piss it
makes me feel better wow so uh so I
think this is how they R this is how I
think the intelligence agencies and
those involved in the murder of Kennedy
This Is How They rationalize it good God
the man's a drug addict he's going to
give away the store to Nikita CRF we
can't trust him in Vienna this is how
they justify two two follow-up questions
there for you one of them is first time
around Trump Never released the Kennedy
stuff and second time around you know
everybody's like come you didn't do it
you know we wanted to have the
information like well you know not yet
and it keeps getting delayed by both
parties yes what's the who the hell is
the group that goes and sits with the
president that claims before they get
elected that we're going to tell the
information of what happens
that convinces them to say listen if
there's one thing you cannot release is
the fact that we killed Kennedy because
if you do CI is going to turn against
you what does that conversation sound
like when they sit with a president well
Trump has been very blunt about this so
in 2017 I brought it to his attention
that the that the presidential records
act the Kennedy assassination records
act meant that everything would be
released during the the first year of
his presidency unless he held any of
back and he said what do you think I
should do I said you should release it
all why wouldn't you it's been at that
point 50 years uh and uh Mike Pompeo the
head of the CIA convinced him uh that
releasing it all would expose our
methods and sources well first of all
the sources part is ridiculous there's
nobody still alive who is involved in
this National Scandal but secondarily if
they were involved in killing an
American president we we really need to
know that so in the end Trump agrees to
hold 20% back I believe that 20% proves
definitively what we learned in the last
couple days Oswald is not the shooter
but more importantly Kennedy is shot
from the front and back there are
multiple Shooters Oswald is well known
to the CIA well known to the FBI they
both deny that uh and now it goes to Joe
Biden and Biden does the same thing he
releases more but he still holds a
little bit back it's time for the
American people to know the complete
truth if you think about the end of the
day Pat if if they release that r and we
find out that the CIA and the
FBI together killed a president what the
CIA and the FBI are just they're
finished it certainly it certainly hurts
their question
but
for the Warren Commission never had the
autopsy photos they were never granted
access to the autopsy photos Lee Harvey
Oswald is tested for powder Burns there
no there the paraffin test comes back
negative he hasn't shot are you saying
that lewell did not pull the trigger
most definitely did not compl set three
minutes max seven Tom I'll give you the
final and I got final question before we
wrap up well I was saying it all points
to LBJ because you take a look at the
things that LBJ did immediately
thereafter and they were countered to
all the things that Kennedy was doing
and then there's there's been wiretaps
and statements that came out of the mob
where they all discussed why are we
being stabbed in the back by Joe Kennedy
using RFK to prosecute all the mobsters
of America except the ones that are on
his lineage
and they actually had considered offing
RFK and they said don't do that because
Kennedy and Joe will flip this country
upside down and there'll be no trials
there'll just be murders and they said
we can't go after Bobby you have to go
after the head of the snake and the
snake was Joe Kennedy the head of the
snake was JFK because JFK's pen in the
White House that gave authority to RFK
attorney general was allowing Joe
Kennedy to conduct a retaliatory Revenge
campaign under the pen of his son the
Attorney General so this is not
conspiracy this is what happened and you
had the mob saying it was happened and
so you look at everything there that's
why she says the mob did it yeah she
right they were interested she's right
last question for you okay John inkley
okay he he's got some interesting
connections to certain people as well
what happened with Reagan was that int
itional was he connected was he sent is
there any the you read about this at
some interesting his brother all this
stuff what do you go with that if you
read my bush the my book the bush crime
family I make a I make my first case
that George HW Bush is complicit in the
assassination attempt on Reagan uh
several things about it first of all the
government has never released any of the
final report uh Leslie stall uh and then
of CBS and Judy Woodruff then of NBC
both report a second shooter on a
balcony above the entrance to Hilton
hotel but when you look at the photos
the news photos he's been cropped out of
the photo I I located the original photo
there it's like with JFK there too many
bullets they're not all accounted for
Reagan is hit from a upward trajectory
but but hinley is crouching uh there are
a lot of questions uh hinkley's Father
John hinley Senior is a partner at
Zapata oil in Texas he is well known to
the Bush family uh Neil Bush one of the
Bush Sons is supposed to meet with John
Hinckley uh Junior's brother for dinner
that night I'm working on a new book to
take the old stuff I already have which
is pretty convincing but add all of the
new stuff that I have uncovered I I I
think um at the time Bush uh and uh
Secretary of State Alexander heg were in
a struggle Over Control the foreign
policy under the Reagan Administration
uh and this was Bush's move to take
control there you go if you want to know
more gang about what uh Roger's been
talking about order the New York time
bestseller the man who killed Kennedy
the case against LBJ the link will be
below and and get the paperback because
it has three extra chapters okay get the
paperback cuz got three extra chapters
and one of you won a signed copy for
those of you guys that did the survey
Rob if we have the name so I can
announce it if uh uh you do have it just
give it if you don't have it sure the
winner is Mississippi Japan
what that's the user's name that's the
user's name Mississippi Japan is the
winner of the signed copy of the man who
killed Ken mississipp Mississippi Japan
and last but not least for those of you
that want to get direct contact with
Roger asking him any questions by the
way when it comes down to strategy this
man's been involved in politics he is
loved he's hated he is criticized he is
feared but the man's got a lot of
experience in politics the last 50 uh
years and he was one of the first if not
the first to say Trump's one day going
to be a president after a conversation
he had with him if you want to get in in
contact with him maybe even have a phone
call or FaceTime with him you can find
him on man rob do we have the link below
as well for manck yes it's in the post
and it's also in the chat if you can go
to the chat and you go to man just click
on it go there DM him he'll respond back
with a video or a text or you can have a
15-3 minute call FaceTime call with the
one and only Roger Stone Roger thanks
for being on this was fantastic gang I
believe we're doing a podcast morning on
Thanksgiving so we will properly wish
you a Happy Thanksgiving on Thanksgiving
take care everybody bye-bye
bye-bye